[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver pour les matins du sénat
aujourd'hui nous parlons d'un sujet qui
occupe largement l'actualité le
coronavirus hier vous le savez deux
nouveaux cas ont été détectés en france
tandis que l'épidémie se répand en
italie ce matin la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat organisait
une audition sur les risques liés aux
coronavirus et sur les mesures prises
par les pouvoirs publics pour éviter sa
transmission
plusieurs professeurs spécialistes du
sujet notamment l'institut pasteur était
entendue je vous propose d'écouter ses
auditions et on se retrouve après je
vois mes collègues
à ma droite et leurs compétences
respectives essayer de le plus
complémentaire possible et vous apportez
peut-être ce que notre un éclairage sur
ce qu'on sait sur l'épidémiologie de ce
nouveau corps d'un virus qui est ma
spécialité donc apprend des choses que
je voudrais dire aussi c'est que les
connaissances que nous avons aujourd'hui
sont susceptibles de changer car il faut
se rappeler que les premiers patients
ont été identifiés en chine il y a de
cela à peine plus de deux mois et que de
virus a été effectivement lui aussi
identifié séquence est mise en ligne le
10 janvier mais que notre compréhension
de ce qui se passe est très évolutive
avec l'avancement des connaissances
il faut aussi savoir que les premières
données dont on disposait sur le plan
épidémiologique nous venaient de nos
collègues chinois c'était des données
agrégées sur des nombres de cas des
nombre de décès mais peu de détails
et depuis qu'il ya des cas exportés à
l'étranger des études avec des données
plus détaillées auxquelles nous avons
accès ont fait évoluer notre
compréhension du mode de propagation de
ce virus alors sur des critères assez
classique en épidémiologie de
propagation le premier dont vous avez
entendu parler qu'on appelle le nombre
de reproduction de base qui et combien
de patients vont être infectées par
chaque malade
eh bien on le retient aujourd'hui un
chiffre qui serait situé entre 2 et 3 et
je le rappelle c'est un chiffre en
absence de mesures de contrôle et
prévention qui est évidemment
susceptible d'évoluer à partir du moment
où vous prenez des mesures de
confinement d'isolement des patients etc
et et le but étant de ramener ce chiffre
à moins de 1 puisque si chaque personne
infectée en affecte moins d'une
d'épidémie s'arrêtera la grande
différence que l'on connaît par rapport
à un autre quand un virus très proche et
qui a été notre modèle au début puisque
c'était notre seule grille de lecture
possible quitté le grand de las virus du
strass réside en fait dans deux
paramètres
alors juste un rappel aux grands navires
du strass vous vous souvenez c'est
l'épidémie de 2003 du sud est de la
chine qui était parti de canton beaucoup
de similitudes avec ce nouveau corps
d'un virus à savoir une origine d'un
animal vendu dans des marchés notamment
animaux sauvages dans le sud de la chine
un corps d'un virus qui génétiquement
est à 80 % identique incarne un virus
qui donne des infections pulmonaires qui
sont plus sévères chez les personnes
âgées notamment celles qui ont des
comorbidités type hypertension et
diabète une surprenante bénédicte et des
formes cliniques chez les enfants et
donc beaucoup de paramètres qui nous
laissait entendre que ces deux corps un
virus était très proche à la fois
génétiquement et cliniquement
néanmoins quand on en vient à la
contagion de différence fondamentale
le corps d'un virus du sras sne était
contagieux que quelques jours après le
début des symptômes on va dire pour
faire simple quatre jours après le début
des symptômes ce qui laissait le temps
une fois les personnes malades de les
diagnostiquer de les isoler avant qu'ils
aient contaminer d'autres personnes et
ça c'était fondamental dans la gestion
de la crise du corps d'un virus du sras
ce deuxième élément important avec le
strass tous les malades avaient des
formes sévères dont ils étaient tous
identifiés et on ne passez pas à côté de
forme bénigne qui aurait pu être
inaperçu
avec ce nouveau coronavirus ce que l'on
a compris récemment était que la
contagion débute avec le début des
symptômes et parfois chez des gens qui
n'ont pas de symptômes ça reste encore
des cas isolés mais et on ne sait pas la
part relative qu'il pèse dans la
transmission de l'épidémie de virus mais
néanmoins c'est un fait en tout cas à
partir du début des symptômes des
patients sont contagieuses qui laisse
beaucoup moins de temps pour les
diagnostics et les isoler et rendra le
contrôle de l'épidémie plus difficile
deuxième élément important c'est que il
existe des formes donc asymptomatiques
ou des formes bénignes des formes
bénignes ses dirigeants qui ne vont pas
être amené à consulter parce qu'ils ne
se trouvent pas assez malade pourra les
consulter
or certains peuvent être contagieux et
dès lors
anticiper à la transmission du virus et
donc là aussi deuxième facteur important
qui fera que l'épidémie sera plus
difficile à contrôler pour les autres
critères épidémiologie classique que
vous on a l'habitude d'évoquer il ya la
durée d'incubation
elle est importante parce que la durée
d'incubation maximale sert à définir la
durée de la quarantaine que l'on impose
au contact des patients puisque on veut
quand on met les gens en quarantaine
leur laisser le temps de développer la
maladie s'il était amené à avoir été
infectés cette durée maximale
bon la quarantaine a été fixé à 14 jours
toutes les estimations que nous avons
aujourd'hui convergent pour une durée
moyenne d'incubation qui serait de six
jours peut-être un peu plus courte et
une durée maximale de douze jours
il y a eu des cas isolés rapporté pour
lesquelles ces durée d'incubation aurait
pu être supérieures aux quatorze jours
qui sont aujourd'hui recommandé pour la
quarantaine néanmoins ça reste des cas
isolés on n'est pas certain non plus
qu'il n'y ait pas eu pour ces personnes
qui étaient en chine
d'autres contacts entre le moment où le
présumé contact affectant et le moment
du développement des symptômes qui a été
tardif et dès lors je pense que des
mesures aujourd'hui de quarantaine fixé
à 14 jours c'est la bonne durée
on n'a pas de raison de changer en vue
des données épidémiologiques cette durée
de quarantaine par rapport à la létalité
qu'il autre paramètre important pour
estimer la gravité potentielle de
l'épidémie
pour vous donner une grille de lecture
simple et peut-être un peu simplifié
mais des ordres de grandeur pour le
strass on considère que 10% des
personnes qui étaient infectées décède
avec ce corner virus l'estimation pour
les formes cliniques est de 1% et pour
la grippe saisonnière je dirais qu'on
est plutôt autour de 1 pour mille
néanmoins c'est des ordres de grandeur
qui peuvent vous être utile 10% 1 % un
pont bill pour avoir une appréciation
ces chiffres peuvent être amenés à
trévise et notamment quand on aura une
meilleure appréciation des formes
réellement bénigne voir asymptomatiques
des infections auquel cas ce taux de
létalité pourrait encore être amené à
diminuer un petit peu mais je pense que
ces ordres de grandeur reste une bonne
grille de lecture aujourd'hui
quant aux personnes qui sont
susceptibles d'être de décéder il y as
on le sait tous et je l'aï déjà dit les
personnes âgées
je vais pas vous donner un critère d'âge
qui n'a pas beaucoup de sens
semées par exemple sur la série publiée
de 45 mille patients chinois
80% des décès et j'ai été chez des
personnes de plus de 60 ans ça veut dire
en miroir que 20% des décès et thé chez
des gens de moins de 60 ans et ça c'est
important parce que c'est probablement
là que émotionnellement il y aura un
impact de l'épidémie quand des gens
jeunes de 30 40 ans vont décéder de ce
nouveau virus c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit avec les grippes pandémiques c'est
quelque chose qu'on a vu avec le strass
il ya donc ce type de deux formes graves
chez des sujets jeunes qui ont un impact
médiatique très important et je le
rappelle est gelée déjà dit pour les
enfants pour l'instant il ya des
infections ce sont des formes cliniques
bénigne je vais peut-être resté jusque
là pour le rap et d'épidémiologique
parce qu'on est nombreux autour de la
table et que c'était voilà les
principaux points en tout cas de de ce
que je pense on sait aujourd'hui sur
l'épidémiologie
merci monsieur madame le port pour la
suite
bonjour à tous et merci de notre
invitation donc je suis responsable
effectivement de la mission corymbe
national dont je vais vous dire quelques
mots
après avoir complété très peu par
rapport à grandes lignes que vient
d'indiquer arnaud fontanet en ce qui
concerne la maladie elle-même il a donné
les grands éléments donc une infection à
présentation très prédominante
respiratoires signes d'infection
respiratoire haute ou basse les formes
basse étant bien sûr celle qui exposent
à la gravité et la survenue de ce que
l'on appelle un syndrome de détresse
respiratoire aiguë c'est à dire une
défaillance des fonctions respiratoires
qui survient dans une proportion faible
de came qui survient avec des chiffres
qui sont maintenant bien connu en effet
dans la série de quarante mille patients
qui vient
d'être publiée par le cc chinois voilà
il y à des formes graves intermédiaires
et en particulier en souligner sa à
l'instant il ya des formes graves
d'apparition un peu retardé c'est à dire
que la malice démarre de façon bénigne
la majorité des cas ces armes la grille
pour face qu'on a déjà tous eu à vrai
dire
et puis vers le 8e 10e jour ya
semble-t-il un certain nombre de
patients
là aussi il n'est pas majeur mais il est
notable qui s'aggrave de façon
conséquente
c'est un processus qui n'est pas très
habituel en maladies infectieuses même
si ça peut se voir sa a été noté très
tôt très tôt dès les premiers patients
observés
il y aura sûrement des phénomènes à
mieux comprendre quand on pourra étudier
de façon plus approfondie avec un peu
plus de recul tout cela voilà donc pour
la maladie je ne dirai rien de plus si
ce n'est à eux tout outil de diagnostic
bien sûr qui a été mis en route dès que
possible avec une mobilisation très
forte des centres nationaux de référence
enfin du centre national de référence
paris lyon et qui a permis que le test
de diagnostic soit mis en place
d'abord soit accessible dans le cnrd des
premiers jours où le texte était calibré
les cliniciens ont pu envoyer des tests
pour savoir si un patient que l'on
appelle suspect puis cas possibles comme
on le classe l'institut de veille
sanitaire santé publique france était un
cas confirmés dont il y avait bien une
infection
1 et ça ça dans la phase initiale de la
maladie c'est très important parce que
un cas confirmé c'est comme une épingle
dans une botte de foin
une immense cité de personnes qui tous
ceux qui ont de la fièvre et au milieu
de cela il faut arriver à trouver les
premiers patients donc les tests sont
fondamentaux ils ont été mis très vite
en route à disposition très vite ensuite
mis en accès dans les établissement
référent qui eux mêmes ont ensuite
besoin de trois quatre jours pour les
calibrer mettre en place et les rendre
opérationnelles c'est en train de
s'étendre davantage preuve que le
directeur général de la santé commentera
plus loin en tout cas c'est un outil
majeur et qui est opérationnel ont fait
le look le diagnostic
alors une fois qu'on a fait
diagnostiquer bien il faut traiter les
patients et la difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il n'ya pas de médicaments qui
est fait réellement la preuve de son
efficacité il ya des pistes de réflexion
avec deux produits qui est est en cours
d'étude et apparaissaient comme des
potentialités médicaments à administrer
et qui ont été administrées chez les
quelques cas français leur md y virent
d'une part qui est un médicament qui
avaient été des bleus développé pour la
fièvre hémorragique ebola
et puis un médicament encore plus ancien
encore plus utilisés qui est le
lopinavir ritonavir qui est un
médicament anti vih
voilà et puis ce matin il ya une bonne
nouvelle semble t'il c'est que peut-être
peut-être à vérifier parce que c'est un
médicament vraiment siens et donc y
revient à chaque fois d'une certaine
façon donc il faut prendre un peu de
recul il ya des données une vie trop
quand même sur le virus sarko v2 qui
suggère que la chloroquine pourrait être
un produit intéressant a testé et il ya
donc des travaux de réflexion dans le
domaine de la recherche en france qui
sont en route avec
toujours est il que ce médicament pour
l'instant laisse entrevoir des
perspectives de recherche thérapeutique
et si bien dans le domaine du traitement
curatif des patients que peut-être même
de la protection des personnels
soignants ce n'est pas à négliger
on en est là on ne peut pas en dire plus
à ce stade sur ce sujet voilà pour la
maladie je m'arrêterai là je vais dire
deux mots de la mission qu aurait
peut-être qui n'est pas une structure se
tait très connu de vous la mission
corymbe est une toute petite structure
il ya six personnes qui travaillent
elle a été créée en 2015 la 5 ans et les
pérenne
depuis deux ans c'est une convention
entre le ministère de la santé la dgs la
dg os
le service de santé des armées la
société de pathologie infectieuse de
langue française et l'ap-hp qui est
porteuse de cette mission
cette mission coreb nationale a pour
objectif d'animer le réseau des
établissements référent pour le risque
épidémique et biologiques en effet donc
entre autres pour ce nouveau virus
l'idée étant que il est indispensable
qu'il y ait sur le territoire un
maillage avec des têtes de pont que sont
les établissement référent et qui font
que si un patient arrive il arrivera
bien sûr jamais frappé à la porte de
l'établissement référent mais ces
établissement référent eux-mêmes anime
le réseau dans leur zone région etc pour
que le premier patient soit au plus vite
repéré et orientés dans la bonne
direction c'est la première mission
générale de la mission coreb et
la deuxième mission qui a été à
l'origine à vrai dire de sa création
c'est l'élaboration de procédure pour la
prise en charge des patients et en
particulier des patients suspects parce
que l'enjeu
à vrai dire c'est de repérer les
patients suspects pour qu'ils puissent
être identifiés comme cas possibles puis
comme qu'à confirmer si tel est le cas
et ces procédures sont des procédures un
peu particulière puisque ce sont des
procédures professionnels
multidisciplinaire c'est-à-dire qu'elle
regroupe des compétences des sociétés
savantes pas seulement d'infectiologie
et de réanimation mais aussi de
microbiologie d'hygiène de pédiatrie est
tout autre en fonction bien sûr de
l'agent infectieux et des pathologies en
cause
voilà et elles sont dites opérationnel
car elles doivent permettre aux
professionnels de santé dans le terrain
de d'être en situation pour prendre en
charge au mieux les patients
donc voila un petit peu la mission
corymbe je suis bien sûr très tôt en
dire plus si vous le souhaitez elle
l'animation passe par une journée
nationale qui a lieu tous les ans au
mois de juin
souvent à l'école du val de grâce et
puis des rencontres avec les cellules et
pas rationnel zonal nous allons
régulièrement rencontrer chaque site
c'est quelque chose de fondamental le
présentiel jeu parce que vous le savez
aussi bien que nous voir les gens parler
et c'est très intéressant parce qu'on se
rend compte que dans les différentes
zones inondables so lu ment pas les
mêmes champs d'intérêt et développer des
travaux et des stratégies
ce qui fait que de collecter toutes ces
expériences de les faire échanger ce
s'interpeller et se renforcer les unes
les autres permet de créer une expertise
collective professionnelle extrêmement
rapide et qui est très utile en
situation comme
cela s'est produit donc dernièrement
puisque très vite les établissements qui
prenait en charge des premiers patients
ont mis en place des échanges échanges
et comment il faisait et ça permet de
très vite ajusté et crée une espèce de
savoirs communs qui peut être très
rapidement ensuite partager avec tous
les autres qui sont bien entendu
demandeurs au cas où il y aurait aussi à
prendre en charge ces patients
voilà ce que pense que c'est l'essentiel
de ce que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
une mission de formation des
professionnels de santé par don qui est
importante
il y a un lien pour ahmad formation qui
est sur le site de la mission corail m a
rappelé un merci monsieur le directeur
général monsieur le président les
sénateurs
je pense que ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure à la fois par le président et
par arnaud fontanet est très intéressant
notamment en termes d'émergence parce
que je crois qu'on s'habitue aux virus
qui circulent vous aurez noté qu'il ya
une certaine indifférence de la société
aux morts tous les tous les hivers de la
grippe 10000 l'année dernière de la même
faute de même façon qu'il ya une
certaine indifférence voire même une
certaine défiance vis-à-vis du vaccin
quand on parle des épidémies de rougeole
parce qu'on a cette habitude de dire oui
il ya des cas de rougeole c'est pas très
grave puisque y en a cette idée de 2min
t alors que malheureusement la rougeole
tue et qu'elle est parfaitement
évitables par la vaccination
donc devant un nouveau virus qui est
quand même le cas on a la confirmation
qu'on est de plus en plus face à des
émergences ça a été rappelé la
mondialisation la démographie galopante
l'urbanisation le réchauffement
climatique
les interfaces multiples entre l'homme
et l'animal et les voyages font qu'on a
une augmentation très nette depuis 30
ans des émergences et on a ça a été dit
par le professeur fontanet énormément
d'incertitudes scientifiques et donc
pour ma part je dois gérer des
incertitudes scientifiques
c'est pas simple mais on a décidé avec
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
agnès buzyn puis avec olivier ferrand de
garder le même principe pour communiquer
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens c'est à
dire de rester factuels rigoureux on dit
ce qui est
avérée on parle de ce que l'on sait de
ce qu'on ne sait pas et transparent ce
qu'on en sait aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
est face à un virus qui est contagieux
qui se transmet par voie respiratoire ce
qui n'est évidemment pas la voie la plus
aisée à combattre qui est
potentiellement contagieux quelques
heures avant l'apparition des symptômes
ou chez des personnes qui ont peu de
symptômes ce qui ne facilite pas le
repérage qui ressemble à la grippe en
termes de clinique en termes de
symptômes
alors qu'on est en pleine épidémie de
grippe ce qui n'est quand même pas là
aussi très simple qui se transmet
aisément entre humains puisque on a
parlé du fameux airs zéro le nombre de
cas secondaires pour un cas et puis il
ya aussi des situation d'hyper
transmission qui ne sont pas liées en
général à la personne mais bien à la
quantité de virus porter ou tout
simplement aux interactions sociales de
cette personne
il est sûr que si vous restez chez vous
et avec peu de contacts si vous allez
régulièrement dans des réunions le
nombre de contacts augmente et c'est ce
qu'on a observé très clairement d'une
part lors du foyer des
contamines-montjoie ou une personne
d'origine britannique a contaminé 12
personnes dans un appartement dans un
chalet donc comme comme quoi le virus
peut vraiment être transmis les aimants
et puis vous avez aussi quelque part une
confirmation expérimentale avec le
paquebot diamond princess où on a eu un
taux d'attaqué comme on dit de près de
20%
c'est à dire que 20% des personnes à
bord ont fini par développer la maladie
ce qui montre que on a des transmissions
pas uniquement d'ailleurs problème en
par voie respiratoire mais
potentiellement aussi entre malades non
diagnostiqués et non malades avec des
circuits qui ont maintenant été
expliquée par les japonais en
particulier des plateaux des plateaux
repas qui était apportée par le
personnel qui potentiellement été
contaminées en france on a été alertée
très tôt il se trouve qu'on a grâce à
santé publique france en particulier de
plus en plus ce qu'on appelle une veille
automatique et une veille syndromique
c'est à dire qu'on est en alerte de tout
ce qui peut se passer dans le monde et
donc la première fois qu'on a évoqué ce
virus émergents c'était le jour où il a
été séquencé se dire je crois le 7
janvier et on a fait une réunion dédiée
sur ce point on a fait un premier
message d alerte aux professionnels et
aux agences le 14 et j'ai placé le
centre opérationnel de régulation de
réception des urgences en vigilance
renforcée le 22
avec la constitution d'un centre de
crise sanitaire dès le 27
donc vous voyez plusieurs jours avant la
déclaration d'une urgence de santé
publique de portée internationale
évidemment la france ne répond pas tout
seul elle a de très nombreuses
interactions avec l'union européenne
donc nous avons de très nombreux nous
aux réunions téléphoniques avec les
experts de l'union européenne notamment
le 6 d'ici européens mais aussi avec le
siège de l'om s et avec des instances de
type g7
j'essaie de santé puisque vous savez que
ministre de la santé peuvent se réunir à
plusieurs reprises sous ce format là on
a opté pour une information très large
des professionnels de santé parce qu'on
avait besoin de les informer de les
mobiliser
mais aussi des protégés parce que je
vous rappelle qu'il ya beaucoup de
cannes nosocomiaux et ya malheureusement
des morts parmi les professionnels de
santé en chine donc on a besoin
évidemment de partager l'information et
ça se fait selon des vecteurs officiel
le vecteur minsanté qui part aux ars le
mars qui part à l'ensemble des
établissements hospitaliers de france et
au service concerné par exemple samu
service d'urgences infectiologie
réanimation et par ailleurs on a aussi
un mail d'alert qui s'appelle dgs
urgents qui est gratuit destiné plutôt
professionnel il ya déjà huit cent mille
abonnés donc à chaque fois que j'en vois
que je clique soient déjà sur gens dans
leur huit cent mille professionnels de
santé reçoivent une information très
précise avec des liens pour pouvoir
télécharger les guides techniques qui
ont été réalisés notamment je les
remercie par coreb sur la prise en
charge des patients mais il ya aussi un
guide pour les professionnels de santé
les établissements de santé qui est en
ligne
il ya des fiches techniques sur la
réalisation du prélèvement sur la
technique de virologie sur l'habillage
tout ça est évidemment fondamental pour
les professionnels de santé que nous
avons réuni déjà à trois reprises en
réunion présentiel avec la plupart des
têtes de pont ordre sociétés savantes
fédération évidemment en associant les
libéraux et les hospitaliers toutes les
agences sanitaires sont mobilisés santé
publique france évidemment et je
laisserais sa directrice générale
s'exprimer mais aussi la nsn pour la
surveillance de l'impact de cette crise
sur les produits de santé
l'agencé de biomédecine et le ffs
puisqu'il ya des restrictions de don du
sang ou de don de cellules ou don
d'organes liées à la situation et puis
le haut conseil de santé publique qui
émet régulièrement des avis sur cette
situation
dès le début nous avons alerté nos
établissement référent il y en avait 38
au début vous savez que maintenant nous
sommes passés à plus de 100 l'objectif
étant que tous les départements est un
gros moins un établissement en alerte en
général sièges de samu
les tests ont été disponibles très
rapidement grâce à l'institut pasteur
qui héberge le centre national de
référence des virus respiratoires
on a décidé de faire des points presse
très régulier on actualise évidemment
avec santé publique france la définition
de cas et ça nous a permis de prendre en
charge un certain nombre d'opérations
que je crois on n'avait pas fait depuis
très longtemps en france d'abord de
rapatrier nos compatriotes qui étaient à
one qui est une zone rouge par des vols
dédié avec une équipe médicale à bord et
avec ensuite une 14ème sur site j'ai
regardé un petit peu l'histoire des
quarantaines en france la dernière
quarantaine en france avait été
prononcée en 1955 à vannes pour la
dernière épidémie de variole voyez qu on
a un peu de recul et donc on a pu mettre
en place une 14/n en france puisqu'on a
les arguments et les grâce à vous la
législation qui le permet dans les ailes
31-31 on peut sur mesure exceptionnelle
des décisions soient de la ministre soit
du préfet se retrouvait donc avec des
personnes qui sont informés qu'ils ont
consentis mais qui savent qu'ils ont
arrêtés individuels de mise en 14 n ça
s'est très bien passé à carry-le-rouet
ça s'est très bien passé à
aix-en-provence et ça se passe très bien
à branville puisque c'est le seul site
qui demeure puisque nous n'avons 28
français qui sont actuellement à bord en
ville dans le calvados et où on leur a
proposé en plus un protocole de
recherche qui est qu'on les a testés
tous à l'arrivée puis cinq jours après
et tous les tests aujourd'hui sont
négatifs ce qui est une évidemment une
bonne nouvelle et ce qui rassure les
voisins qui savent que les personnes qui
sont en isolement ne sont pas malades
on a actuellement fait plus de plus de
1000 tests à la fois sur des cas
possibles sur des personnes rapatriées
ou sur des personnes contact à haut
risque symptomatique
on a beaucoup renforcer l'information
des voyageurs et donc j'encourage tous
nos concitoyens à consulter très
régulièrement le site diplomatie.gouv.fr
qui évolue tous les jours
de la même façon à renforcer
l'information des voyageurs au retour
avec des messages à bord et des messages
à l'arrivée avec des affiches des flyers
des messages audio en anglais en
français et en chinois
c'est pas évident mais tous les
aéroports internationaux l'ont fait
santé publique france a mis en place une
mobilisation de la réserve pour
l'accueil à charles de gaulle et donc on
a aussi évidemment mobilisé des stocks
stratégiques puisque vous savez que nous
disposons là encore grâce à santé
publique france 2 stocks stratégiques
notamment de masques chirurgicaux
le ministre a confirmé nous avons fait
une commande urgente pour les
professionnels de santé de masques
protecteurs dits ffp2 nous avons mis en
place un numéro vert pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens le 0 800 30 000 qui
reçoit beaucoup d'appels 18000 hier nous
avons une page dédiée officielle sur le
site du gouvernement des sites officiels
que nous rappelons régulièrement santé
diplomatie santé publique france où ses
nerfs et donc la situation
épidémiologique aujourd'hui a encore
évolué je viens de l'annoncer par un
point presse il ya une demi heure
nous avons désormais 17 cas on se guérit
cinq hospitalisées et deux décédés nous
avons mis en place aussi au niveau
régional un plan spécifique qui est le
plan horse and qui est intéressant
puisque c'est un plan spécifique du
système de santé face à une situation
sanitaire exceptionnel afflux massif de
victimes canicule risque nucléaire est
donc là nous avons activé la partie
risque épidémique et biologiques qui a
été beaucoup travaillé avec les ars
évidemment en lien étroit avec les
préfets puisque l'objectif est qu on
articule parfaitement le plan enr san
avec le plan orsec et de la même façon
que une instruction va partir
aujourd'hui ou demain au plus tard au
préfet pour que l'île se coordonne
parfaitement avec les ars pour la
réponse face par exemple à une chaîne de
transmission ou un cluster en région
enfin au plan interministériel il ya une
très forte mobilisation le premier
ministre a réuni à trois reprises
l'ensemble de son gouvernement sur ce
sujet il ya évidemment beaucoup de
réunions interministérielles
le sgdsn on peut secrétaire général de
la défense et de la sécurité nationale
est en appui de la dgs pour tout ce qui
est planification le service
d'information du gouvernement est en
appui pour tout ce qui est communication
la task force interministériel et réunit
cet après midi à 14
il ya un guide d'aidé à la décision pour
les autorités ministérielles et donc
notre stratégie en france elle est très
claire
ça peut vous paraître un peu simple mais
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment ça l'enjeu
c'est de freiner la diffusion puisque
des comptes est quelqu'un des cons
l'isolent on empêche d'avoir des
contacts et c'est vraiment
si simple que ça c'est à dire qu'une
maladie terriblement contagieuse si le
malade est isolé il n'y a pas de cas
secondaires
voilà c'est vraiment cette image qu'il
faut retenir et c'est aussi l'image que
je donne souvent de du parallèle entre
une épidémie et un incendie plus
l'alerté précoce plus vous envoyer des
moyens rapidement plus l'incendié
rapidement circonscrit même chose pour
une épidémie si on passe à côté deux cas
qui donne des cas secondaires qui donne
des cathares sierre on a beaucoup de
retard
ensuite dans la réaction et on se fait
déborder donc on réduit aussi l'impact
au maximum donc avec toutes les
stratégies qui vous ont été évoqués
évidemment l'hospitalisation dans les
services référent et l'accès à des
traitements innovants
il ya des principes tout simple qu'il
faut rappeler et en particulier devant
des représentants du peuple qui sont que
l'hygiène générale est fondamentale on
parle beaucoup des masques mais les
masses n'ont aucun sens si on ne se lave
pas les mains puisque en pratique on
touche des surfaces contaminées si
quelqu'un éternue et cinq minutes avant
vous et et qu' il n'a pas suivi les
mesures barrières vous contaminer les
mains c'est un c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il faut rappeler un l'hygiène
des mains est fondamental de la même
façon on va largement diffusé la
doctrine d'utilisation des masques elle
est assez simple les masques dits
chirurgicaux sont en fait des masques
anti-projections c'est à dire qu'en fait
ils protègent les autres de vos
symptômes c'est le masque tout simple
standard mais qui permet de ne pas
contaminer les autres donc c'est réservé
aux malades ou aux personnes contactent
potentiellement contagieuse et puis on
souhaite vraiment passer le message que
des masques de protection respiratoire
les masques p2 les masques diana qui
sont en fait difficile à porter parce
qu'il freine beaucoup il empêche
vraiment de respirer sont vraiment
réservé aux professionnels de santé de
toute la chaîne transports sanitaires
secours à personnes pompiers
ambulanciers et médecins évidemment
libéraux infirmiers il faut à toutes les
personnes qui sont en contact étroit
avec les malades mais pas les autres ça
n'a pas de sens quand on est un citoyen
qui va faire ses courses d'avoir un
masque de protection respiratoire
puisque la distance de contacts et de 1
mètre et que c'est vraiment les gestes à
risque qui contamine quand on a un tuba
patients quand on examine quand on fait
des soins en tant qu'infirmier ou non en
tant que kiné donc voilà pour les soins
et on pourra répondre évidemment à
toutes vos questions et puis enfin je
voudrais insister sur un point important
la france est bien placée en termes de
recherche grâce au consortium reacting
qui est un consortium multi acteurs de
recherche qui permet de réagir en
urgence a été le cas pour osi kapoor
ebola
l'institut pasteur est évidemment s'est
mobilisée mais tous les acteurs de
recherche sont mobilisés on a facilité
aussi l'examen en urgence par des cpp de
protocoles de recherche pour les tests
pour les essais thérapeutiques donc
toute la communauté scientifique et
médicale française étant mobilisés en
sachant qu évidemment les efforts seront
essentiellement internationaux sûr il
serait une telle sur un tel défi je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame chen bonjour
monsieur le président ces messieurs je
vais commencer par eux un rappel de
concernant santé publique france 2 qui
est une une des agences sanitaires qui
travaille évidemment en lien étroit et
sous la tutelle de du ministère de la
santé
donc sans public france est en situation
de pré alerte depuis le 7 janvier et on
se le 10 janvier pardon est en situation
d' alerte depuis le 13 janvier ça
suppose en particulier une réunion de
coordination interne tous les jours
évidemment des astreintes autant que
nécessaire et je vais décrire pour
accomplir qu'elle pour accomplir nos
missions
et puis évidemment un certain nombre de
réorganisation en interne pour faire
face au surcroît de charges liées à nos
missions
donc en effet on a publié la définition
de cas française le 10 janvier la veille
de celle de l' oms
et pour rappel selon les cdc européens
ont publié la leur le 31 janvier mes
enfants parfaits lien avec la direction
générale de la santé comme le directeur
général a rappelé il nous semblait
important de pouvoir disposer d'une
définition de cas alors que nous
discutons bien évidemment avec
l'ensemble de nos collègues européens et
aussi avec l'om est ce de la manière la
plus précoce possible pour pouvoir aussi
de manière cohérente diffuser un certain
nombre d'informations à l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé en particulier
on a aussi conscience où on avait
évidemment conscience puisqu'on en
assurent la surveillance de l'épidémie
grippe concomitante et du fait que cela
constitue pour
la surveillance de la maladie mais aussi
pour la prise en charge un certain
nombre de situations diagnostic
différentiel qui ne sont pas simples
santé blick français sur donc la
surveillance épidémiologique veille
scientifique donc il ya aussi un gros
travail de documentation et de veille
scientifique parce que c'est une agence
scientifique et que comme l'a rappelé le
directeur général de la santé on est
très vigilants à vérifier l'ensemble des
informations dont on dispose et à
fournir un certain nombre d'éléments
d'analysé qui sont fondées sur des
données probantes et enfin on a
évidemment des liens permanents avec nos
homologues à l'échelon international et
en particulier à l'échelon européen des
autres agences sanitaires
ce qui permet aussi de partager un
certain de l'expérience et de bonnes
pratiques sur le plan de l'investigation
donc nous sommes chargés en lien dont
les cellules en région en particulier en
lien étroit avec les agences régionales
de santé de l'investigation des cas donc
de l'histoire des cas possibles du
dénombrement des contacts est évidemment
de l'appui aussi au classement du niveau
de risque de ses différents contacts
puisque en fonction du niveau de risque
estimé il y à une doctrine de mesures de
gestion et comme l'a souligné le
directeur général de la santé nous en
sommes aujourd'hui à un certain nombre
de cas confirmés est pris en charge qui
sont liées à l'épidémie en chine
directement ou indirectement dans ce cas
il est tout à fait justifié grâce à la
détection précoce grâce à l' isolement
et grâce à l'identification et au suivi
actif de l'ensemble des contacts de
continuer une stratégie d'endiguement
très active ce qui permet de contrôler
le démarrage de la chaîne de
transmission et de la maîtrise et le
plus longtemps possible dans une
situation
il a été parfaitement souligné que le
virus est extrêmement transmissibles
nous évaluons également donc le stade
d'épidémie regard de ces données au sein
du pays et fournissons aussi les
scénarios possibles d'évolution au
ministère de la santé le directeur
général de la santé l'a souligné nous
avons mobilisé les réservistes de la
réserve sanitaire donc dans quatre
situations maintenant à charles de
gaulle et aussi auprès des
ressortissants donc revenu dans les
trois centres où ils ont effectué leurs
périodes de quatorze haine et nous
fournissons également un certain nombre
de travaux sur les outils de prévention
et en particulier la promotion des
gestes barrières et des gestes d'hygiène
à l'ensemble de la population ce qui est
pas inconnu ce sont les mêmes gestes que
dans le cas de la grippe par exemple
sachant que pour ce virus ne disposons
pour l'instant même si les espoirs tous
les espoirs grâce à la recherche sans
permis ni de traitement ni de vaccin
bien entendu nous constituons et nous
mobilisons les stocks stratégiques de
l'état effectivement et nous construit
bus ont aussi autant que possible dans
des protocoles communs avec reacting là
aussi en tant qu'enjeu agences
scientifiques à la recherche pour
évidemment accélérer la production de
nouvelles connaissances dans une
situation qui a été rappelé qu' une
situation de grande incertitude en
particulier sur la létalité sur le
niveau de gravité potentielle avec un
élément néanmoins rassurant pour une
tranche d'âge c'est la tranche d'âge des
enfants
même sur les 40 plus de 40000 45 milles
autour de 45000 premier cas confirmé en
chine
on voit bien que le
niveau de gravité de mortalité chez les
enfants est très faible voire égal à
zéro au dessous des jeunes donc au
dessous de 20 ans ce qui est évidemment
pas complètement rassurant mais au moins
pour cette tranche d'âge déjà une
situation nous disposons d'informations
assez probantes
je reste bien sûr à votre disposition
pour répondre à toutes les questions
merci beaucoup mesdames messieurs je
vais immédiatement passé la parole au
collègue monsieur daudigny a été le
premier à réagir
merci le président remercie beaucoup
pour la somme d'informations précises
mais dans ce que vous nous avez
communiqué alors trois questions si vous
permettez première relative aux
aéroports les aéroports français sont
ils ou doivent-ils selon vous être
équipé de portail le thermique pour
repérer les cas symptomatiques du
nouveau donc coronavirus le cas échéant
le plus tôt possible à l'isolement-- à
la prise en charge des personnes
concernées quel est le nombre
aujourd'hui deux chambres d'isolement
met une pression négative on dispose en
métropole et outre-mer et le nombre
d'établissements de santé et
correspondants
cela vous paraît-il suffisants pour
faire face à l'actuelle donc urgence que
vous avez décrite
deuxième question les dernières données
publiées par les équipes chinoises
suggèrent une transmission interhumaine
avérée par contact manuportée ou
aéroportée vous l'avez évoqué pensez
vous qu hôpital soient exposés à un
risque élevé de transmission nosocomiale
dans le cas donc de ce nouveau
coronavirus et une troisième question
peut-il différentes
nous avons renforcé à deux reprises nous
dispositif de gestion des crises
sanitaires exceptionnel dans la loi de
financement pour 2019 et la dernière loi
santé de juillet 2019
nous avons ainsi renforcé les pouvoirs
des directeurs généraux des ars en
matière de réquisition de biens de
services de professionnels de santé et
l'établissement pour faire face à une
urgence sanitaire
pensez vous que cet arsenal juridique
soit suffisant pour mobiliser nos
ressources et nous établissements quelle
évaluation faites-vous à ces égards de
la collaboration entre les ars et les
collectivités territoriales
dans la gestion des crises sanitaires
telles que celles que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui je vous remercie
merci bien j'ai neuf sénateurs inscrits
au fait trois par trois sa part les deux
autres encore madame de roche oui
monsieur le président est vraiment merci
à vous tous de devenir devant devant le
sénat c'est vrai qu'on sent dans
l'opinion publique une inquiétude vous
l'avez dit c'est un peu paradoxal où on
sait le peu de couverture vaccinale
concernant la grippe mais là on est sur
un virus qui viennent chine qui est qui
inquiète donc merci de ces informations
dont on sent bien qu'elles sont
évolutives et quel que vous les ajuster
jour après jour mais on sent à travers
vous pour vous que l'état et est
mobilisée sur ce sujet moi j'avais
plusieurs questions la première c'est
celle des directives qui sont élaborées
par la corrèze est ce qu'on vous sentez
que la communauté soignante under
largement aux directives que vous donnez
et qu'on peut être assurée sur sur ce
point le deuxième point c'était est ce
que vous êtes dans des restrictions
d'accès à des lieux sensibles comme les
établissements d'hébergement de
personnes âgées ou des eaux des lieux de
garde collective pour les enfants et
puis le dernier point concerne à la fois
le traitement parce que sur la
chloroquine en a entendu en disant mais
c'est formidable ça va être le nouveau
traitement et en plus c'est pas
dangereux d'eau d'où ne s'était passé a
noté que ça donc
quelle est votre opinion par rapport aux
traitements spécifiques et sur le vaccin
est ce que le
la rapidité des mutations du virus et
rend impossible la perspective d'un
vaccin dans des délais raisonnables
par ailleurs l'institut pasteur a fait
appel à des dons comment l'état va
s'engager financièrement
comment l'état s'engage financièrement
dans la recherche d'un vaccin
monsieur amiel oui trois questions la
première question concerne les tests
diagnostiques pcr ou autre y at il à un
moment donné dans l'évolution de la
maladie
à partir du moment où elle est
asymptomatique jusqu'à ce qu'elle
devienne symptomatique et donc et aussi
contagieuse des trous dans la raquette
si je peux me permettre autrement dit
des défauts négatif
deuxième question que madame de rochas a
posé mais que je généralise plus quid de
la fiabilité des publications chinoises
j'écoute m20 me didier raoul avec le
côté spectaculaire qu'on lui connaît en
la matière dire voilà cette publication
est très fiable mais pour des raisons
qui sont ce qu'elles sont elles ne sont
pas acceptés à l'international alors est
ce qu'on peut considérer que cette
publication chinoise à laquelle il fait
référence concernant l'efficacité de la
chloroquine dans ce type de pathologie
et fiable ou pas et troisième question
plus politique puisque on se rend bien
compte que d'un débat santé publique on
glisse vers un débat de communication et
aussi de politique
certains commencent à aborder la la
fermeture des frontières
est-ce qu'il n'est pas nécessaire sans
minimiser l'importance de la pathologie
de dhr et de dédramatiser car même la
situation d'un point de vue politique
merci je vous laisse répondre à ces neuf
questions qui commencent
monsieur salomé peut-être commencer et
puis je laisserai les scientifiques
continuer sur un certain nombre de
sujets sport des scientifiques alors
vous avez posé la question des portails
thermique
c'est pas une décision strictement
française c'est vraiment un consensus
international scientifique sur leur
absence d'efficacité pour plusieurs
raisons on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans
d'autres épidémies
on n'a jamais réussi à capter des cas où
les loups la majorité des cas parce par
ceux disponibles pour pour plein de
raisons que je peux vous citer d'abord
vous savez que quand on a une infection
on peut avoir des pics de fièvre et puis
une heure après plus de fièvre on peut
masquer la fièvre très facilement avec
du paracétamol anti inflammatoires on
peut être fébrile a par moment et ne
plus l'être avant où on peut être
malades contagieux mais ne pas présenter
de fièvre donc ça donne énormément de
2,2 biais il ya ensuite le tout le
système de même en cas de détection
qu'est-ce qui se passe
donc il ya toute une organisation qui
était très complexe et tous les pays qui
l'ont fait de nombreux billets en fait
on loupé l'écart entre guillemets
excusez moi ce terme mais on n'en
notamment au site beaucoup l'italie où
les états unis qui se sont fait avoir de
cette façon là de la même façon que les
rapatriements qui ont été faits ont
concerné des personnes qui étaient
négatives et qui ensuite ont été testées
positives alors qu'elle était
objectivement sans fièvre et et sans
symptôme donc c'est vraiment une
polémique je pense qu'il va falloir
balayé en disant c'est pas la bonne
technique ça rassure probablement en
visuellement tout le monde mais le
dispositif doit être beaucoup plus fin
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que fait santé
publique france à l'arrivée à charles de
gaulle puisque je pense que la vraie
réponse est les soignantes ne pas
hésiter à répondre à des questions on
pouvoir examiner un patient pouvoir le
tester s'il ya une inquiétude
plutôt que d'avoir un passage
systématique de vente devant important
deuxième question vous avez posées par
l'équipe vraiment pour moi sur les
chambres
donc nous avons en france la chance
d'avoir à la fois des chambre à pression
négative et des chambres d'isolement ça
peut vous paraître une différence mais
c'est important ça veut dire que ce sont
des draps des capacités d'isolement avec
des capacités de renouvellement de l'air
qui sont importantes on n'est pas obligé
d dans une chambre à pression négative
pour ce type de patients ont le bon le
fait dans beaucoup d'autres pathologies
introduction respiratoires et donc sur
le premier audit que j'ai demandé au
moins sur no no no 108 établissements on
est déjà de pas plus de 2400 lee
de maladies infectieuses d'une part de
soins intensifs ou de réanimation dont
on a on a pas de sujet aujourd'hui sur
la prise en charge de temps qui je pense
que en termes de doctrine il faudra
réserver ses chambres à des cas graves
et qu'on peut parfaitement imaginer que
les formes bénignes soit à la maison et
c'est exactement ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs en italie les enfants
positifs sont à la maison et c'est
d'ailleurs probablement beaucoup mieux
pour les familles donc moi je suis
attentif surtout risque de formes graves
et aux risques réanimatoires puisque
vous savez que par définition les
capacités de réanimation sont sont
limités et donc là c'est le sujet de
l'accès à des lits de réanimation alors
qu'il ya d'autres indications
donc faut pas oublier qu'on n'est pas
non plus des enjeux de perte de chance
pour d'autres patients qui font un
accident vasculaire cérébral ou un
infarctus parce qu'on va leur dire que
tous les lits de réanimation son prix
donc ça c'est un vrai sujet qui est un
sujet des tic un sujet de déontologie et
de la même façon il faut qu'on soit
capable de répondre à des enjeux lourds
on l'a vu en chine par exemple
d'utilisation dès que mots qui sont des
techniques lourde circulation
extracorporelle la mortalité comme l'a
rappelé madame chen est importante je
suis plutôt chez des adultes
alors certes les jeunes semblent son
protégé mais moi ce qui me ce qui me
frappe un peu c'est quand même la
mortalité observée chez des personnes
jeunes moins de 75 ans donc mais avec
avec un taux plus important que la
grippe
et puis par ailleurs quand il ya des
formes graves ya effectivement une
mortalité importante donc il faut qu'on
soit attentif à cette impasse vous avez
posé la question de l'adhésion des
directives laisserait que catherine ne
pas répondre pour les professionnels je
pense que effectivement moi je suis très
attentif à la formation de terrain 1 au
dernier kilomètre dire que c'est bien
d'avoir manié des magnifiques directive
est un guide mais encore faut-il qu'ils
soient connus par les professionnels sur
site par les libéraux donc on est
vraiment attentifs à ça même chose pour
les questions vous avez posées sur les
ehpad on travaille beaucoup avec
l'ensemble des ehpad
d'une part pour savoir quelle conduite
tenir puisque c'est là une population
france ou franchement cibles du virus
les populations fragiles donc comment
réagir quels sont les indications
d'hospitalisation comment prendre en
charge un foyer d'infection respiratoire
aiguë dans une ehpad et puis pour
terminer sur votre question plutôt
politique donc chloroquine et vaccins je
laisserai les les scientifiques répondre
l'arsenal législatif grâce à vous et
plutôt de qualité nous permet de réagir
de façon adaptée je pense un entre vous
le sénateur amiel a déposé récemment et
défendu une brebis sans loi sur ce sujet
on est vraiment dans le cadre de la
sécurité sanitaire donc on adapte à
chaque fois le dispositif mais
globalement je pense qu'il est adapté de
même que la collaboration entre ars
collectivités locales préfet se passe
bien vous avez vu qu'a eu des
communiqués ou des points presse qui ont
été faits à la fois par les ars et les
préfets je pense que ça rassure nos
concitoyens que d'avoir une
communication de proximité
il y aura par exemple une communication
dans quelques heures
à beauvais au sujet du cas grave damien
donc je pense que les gens ont besoin de
mobiliser les maires les élus locaux et
la rs les recteurs tous ceux qui sont
concernés par l'investigation et enfin
sur la fermeture des frontières
évidemment il faut dédramatiser parce
que ça là on est vraiment sur des
mesures qui n'ont pas de sens
scientifique puisque aujourd'hui le
virus circule on le voit dans plus de 40
pays
les gens circulent complètement
librement dans l'espace schengen et
l'image qui est qui était donné par
olivier ferrand et me paraît assez juste
c'est à dire que l'italie c'est presque
la france on circule complètement entre
l'italie et la france et français s'ils
rendent extrêmement souvent et
finalement si on transpose sur le
territoire français on aurait du mal à
imaginer qu'on mette des frontières
entre l'occitanie et paca et c'est à peu
près la même chose compte tenu de
l'intensité des échanges
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens peut-être il
ya des propositions mais voilà je pense
que mes mais il va falloir l'expliquer
c'est à dire qu'en fait le message de
deux épidémiologistes et que jeter un
grand filet de pêche pour attraper une
fourmi n'a pas de sens c'est un petit
peu ça par contre il faut qu'on soit
capable d'attraper la fourmi est donc
d'attraper tous les cas suspects et les
cas confirmés dit de pouvoir
effectivement comme le disait madame
chen identifier les chaînes de
transmission c'est ça la bonne réponse
donc c'est d'avoir une alerte précoce
une détection précoce un isolement
précoce pour pouvoir faire de la
définition de cas contacts et ensuite
suivre toute cette chaîne
pour éviter les contaminations massive
en l'absence de réaction mais ça va être
effectivement un enjeu de communication
très très très important je poursuis sur
trois points les portails juste pour
compléter avec les dernières les
derniers résultats d'une étude de
modélisation de nos collègues anglais de
l'école de santé publique de londres qui
ont estimé que la moins de la moitié des
cas pour être détectées par les mesures
thermiques d'entrée et de sortie avec
des portails thermique donc que ça vient
évidemment à l'appui de ce que dit le
directeur général de la santé ce qui est
mis en place à charles de gaulle c'est
évidemment avec les réservistes la
possibilité que eux mêmes prennent la
température avec un appareil individuel
donc les portails thermique parce que
eux-mêmes dont une sensibilité limitée
parce qu'unique asymptomatiques
on voit bien qu'ils ne présentent pas
d'efficacité très importante pour
détecter les cas de manière suffisamment
sensible sur le point de la transmission
nosocomiale je peux vous donner votre
appelé les chiffres de l'étude chinoises
dont on considère que l'esl et les
centres de contrôle des maladies de
chine nous fournissent des données
fiables et qui sont publiés donc ces 40e
près de 40 sur les près de 45000
premiers cas confirmés 1716 exactement
donc à peu près 4 % étaient des
professionnels de santé
est ce qu'on remarque dans cette
publication c'est que les deux tiers
venait de et aux orane donc la ville
initial de l'épidémie et +23 % de la
région du roubaix donc ça fait une très
grande majorité presque 90% des
professionnels de santé qui ont été
infectés qui venait duroux bay alors
évidemment ça ça permet aussi de tirer
quelques conclusions sur le fait que la
préparation du système de santé et la
disponibilité des mesures de gestion et
en particulier des masques adapté ffp2
est importante parce que on peut estimer
sans doute que dans cette région là où
il ya eu la majorité des cas mais aussi
des décès on peut interpréter que le
délai de prise en charge que a sans
doute contribué à une charge sur le
système de santé et donc l'infection
vraisemblable par transmission de l'eau
comme yann des professionnels de santé
sur sur l'art side l'arsenal législatif
je me permets de redire ou de remercier
à nouveau la commission qui vous a
auditionné sur la proposition du
sénateur amiel et en particulier la
prise en compte de nos commentaires et
nos suggestions par rapport au fait que
pour nous il est extrêmement important
de pouvoir disposer d'un système de
remontée des données qui nous permet de
les analyser en temps réel et de manière
donc à pouvoir analyser à la fois la
situation mais aussi les scénarios
d'évolution donc je crois pouvoir vous
remercier d'avoir pris en compte ces ses
suggestions l'aï rappelé l'importance de
pouvoir disposer d'un système qui permet
de remonter les données un échelon
coordonnées on pourra analyser la
situation de l'italie en particulier
mais c'est vrai que en france on dispose
d'un système qui est coordonné fortement
à l'échelon national même si bien
entendu chaque région a ses propres
prérogatives et et en particulier au
niveau des agences régionales de santé
et que la consolidation à l'échelon
national de l'ensemble des données
permet aussi d'avoir une analyse globale
est utile pour l'ensemble du pays
je vais compléter sur la réanimation les
lits de fix you logis de réanimation
c'est une préoccupation qui est en train
de devenir plus prégnante compte tenu de
la perspective et de la préparation à
une petite île que phénomène de plus
grande ampleur vous nous avez donc saisi
vous essayez aussi le haut conseil sur
cette question et je rappelle simplement
que cette question s'est posée bien sûr
lors de la pandémie grippale de 2009
qu'il y a une dimension éthique que il
faut absolument intégrer dans cette
préparation est associée à la démarche
de prise en charge qui sont en fait
comme vous nous l'avez demandé je pense
dans le cadre du haut conseil de santé
publique
ça c'est une première remarque je
reviens sur la transmission nosocomiale
un instant là aussi dans la perspective
que les cabinets médicaux vont être sans
doute extrêmement sollicités et la
nécessité que il dispose des masqués ou
des kits peut-être de protection
appropriée on entend déjà les médecins
libéraux dire oui mais on n'a pas or si
effectivement on veut protéger l'hôpital
pour qu'il puisse se consacrer aux
patients les plus gras avec
effectivement toutes les formes bénignes
qui sont quand même le la part la plus
importante de la maladie soit prise en
prenant en charge dans des conditions
dilatoire il faut absolument assurer ces
professionnels que les outils de
protection sont disponibles pour eux on
entend ça déjà il y en a qui commencent
à nous faire remonter c'est très
important en ce qui concerne la
l'impact des fiches de la mission corep
je peux pas vous dire on avait au
programme de faire une étude d'impact
mais on arrêtait temporairement vu qu'il
fallait faire autre chose et que je
répète nous sommes tout petit nombre de
personnes pour travailler et dort
mobiliser totalement sur l' alerte
ce sont des fiches qui sont destinés aux
tout premiers soignants qui voit les
premiers patients je reviens l'image
évoquée par le directeur général qui est
le feu de forêt l'objectif c'est que des
premiers soignants qui voit les premiers
patients sachent comment réagir de façon
adaptée et sans non plus à l'armée de
façon excessive et solliciter trop les
structures il nous semble mais c'est
très beau geste que elle apporte une
certaine satisfaction puisqu'on continue
de nous demander de les élaborer
régulièrement tout au moins certains
sont satisfaits
on a l'objectif de faire une vraie
mesure d'impact mais c'est un gros
travail et on n'a pas les moyens de le
faire pour l'instant
voilà je tairai un mot sur les tests
diagnostiques qui sont bien sûr très
important pour les cliniciens ça a été
beaucoup discuté dans le cadre du haut
conseil en particulier sur pattes en
diagnostic mais c'est vrai que quand tu
as testé négatif est que la clinique
primes bien on refait le destin et les
virologues sont totalement d'accord
c'est pas propre à cette maladie
les tests n'ont pas l'air de plus
négatif que dans d'autres maladies
infectieuses c'est une règle habituelle
et cette question des tests négatifs a
aussi été discuté pour savoir sur quels
critères on pouvait laisser sortir les
patients donc il ya des recommandations
qui vont bientôt nous être transmises en
ce sens mais effectivement il est
raisonnable de contrôle et dans certains
cas la négativité car il n'ya des
phénomènes de rebond dont l'amplitude
la fréquence est probablement modeste
mais encore sous réserve d incertitude
mentionné en introduction juste
compléter sur les quelques points qui
restent je vais mettre ensemble la
chloroquine et la fiabilité des
publications chinoises puisque ce sont
les deux sujets se rejoignent en tout
cas pour ce point précis alors le seul
et publications en général il faut
savoir qu'il ya aujourd'hui une quantité
incroyable de journaux médicaux et que
vous pouvez publier toujours un article
vous trouverez toujours un article qui
vous prendra alors on sait quels sont
les publications qui sont réputés avec
un système de revue par les pairs qui
permettent vraiment de garantir une
qualité d'information c'est très connu
il faut savoir que les auteurs chinois
sont très présents dans ces revues dans
le jeu si 13,27 new england jama toutes
les premières publications nous viennent
des auteurs chinois
là il ya eu une revue par des pairs
internationaux qui garantit une certaine
qualité d'information avec on le sait
tous un peu de recul malgré tout parce
que c'est des données qui sont
recueillies extrêmement rapidement donc
on n'a pas la même vérification que l'on
peut la voir dans des publications
classique
il ya aussi un autre système maintenant
qu'on appelle le président qui nous
permet de mettre en ligne des articles
avant même qu'il soit revu par nos pairs
parce qu'on veut dans des circonstances
d'urgence gagner les quinze jours trois
semaines que cette revue peut prendre
etc des articles sont malgré tout
destiné à prêt pour aller dans les très
grandes revues donc là je dirais pour ce
qui est des prêts print comme pour ce
qu'il ya doute cette multitude de revue
qui existe maintenant à l'international
c'est notre jugement d'experts qui
compte et vous avez à ce moment-là
l'exercer en vous demandant prenant un
peu de recul par rapport à ce papier
très souvent on voit très vite quand
c'est un travail de qualité ou pas donc
c'est quand on est habitué c'est
vraiment facile de faire la part des
choses et donc ça arrive pour ce fameux
fameuse étude sur la chloroquine qui a
déjà été évoquée ce matin donc le papier
a été publié en ligne récemment j'ai pas
les détails de ce que j'ai compris sa
comparse concerné dix sites un essai
comparatif contre placebo il y a très
peu d'informations dans ce papier on
nous dit juste que ca raccourci la durée
de la positivité des tests et peut-être
la guérison des patients mais pour
l'instant c'est extrêmement faibles
comme niveau d'information et donc je
serai très prudent sur l'état ce
diagnostic juste sur la cinétique parce
que je suis je me demande si la question
ne portait pas là dessus et bien ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que les gens ont
typiquement des tests diagnostiques
quand on parle du prélèvement
nasopharyngé une recherche du virus en
pcr positif pendant la durée des
symptômes
ça peut commencer un peu avant ça peut
durer un peu après les symptômes mais
globalement c'est cette période ce qui
veut dire que si vous faites le test
trop tôt ça peut être négatif et devenir
positif quelques jours plus tard et et
que donc on peut avoir quelques fois ses
contradictions qui ont été relevés dans
la presse mais qui sont tout à fait
attendu maintenant je pense
qu'aujourd'hui vu les capacités
d'exercer des tests diagnostiques sur le
territoire français c'était sont faits
pour des personnes qui sont
symptomatiques qui ont sont passés par
le 15 avec toutes les procédures que
vous connaissez aujourd'hui sur quand
est-ce qu'on doit appeler le 15
parce qu'on peut pas rassurer l'ensemble
des gens qui voudraient avoir un test ce
serait simplement logistiquement
impossible et donc je crois que c'est
réservé je parle sous le contrôle de de
mes collègues à droite aux personnes qui
sont dans des circonstances très
spécifique je voudrais rassurer les
sénatrices et sénateurs qui m'ont déjà
entendu sur d'autres maladies
infectieuses on n'est pas dans la même
polémique sur la difficulté de la
qualité des tests on est vraiment sur
une recherche par pcr
c'est à dire une technique quand même
très efficace de biologie moléculaire on
leur cherche le génome du virus donc la
vraie difficulté c'est la qualité du
test lui-même c'est-à-dire comment est
ce qu'on fait le prélèvement donc là
effectivement il faut un professionnel
qui sait faire un prélèvement puisqu'on
n'est pas sûr du sanguin on est sur du
respiratoires donc il faut aller frotter
l'épithélium au fond de la gorge ou
fondue n'est pas très agréable mais
c'est pas très méchant pour avoir du
virus donc c'est plutôt c'est plutôt un
examen très fiable est alors en termes
de stratégie aujourd'hui la stratégie la
suivante évidemment quelqu'un qui
revient d'une zone où circule le virus
donc ces zones sont définies par
satellite france quelqu'un qui est
contacts
et 3 d'un malade votre conjoint est
malade on fait un test parce que vous
avez passé huit jours avec votre
conjoint ou et 7 l'élément nouveau qu'on
a rajouté il ya quelques jours un
tableau grave inexpliqué l'idée étant
d'aller chercher un cas qu'on n'aurait
pas relié à une autre histoire pour
avoir une espèce d d'événements
sentinelle devant un tableau de plus
money sévère de détresse respiratoire
aiguë pour lesquels le bilan est négatif
on ne trouve pas de cause de la je pense
qu'il faut discuter évidemment avec les
cliniciens et vie des ministres mais
c'est intéressant aussi d'avoir cette
approche de recherche systématique
devant un tableau il expliqué et je
terminerai avec la question sur les
vaccins et puis donc la campagne de dons
à l'insu pasteur lors la campagne le dos
un bon vous savez que pasteur vie de la
générosité du public en grande partie 1
c'est à peu près un tiers de nos revenus
de ces quelque chose qui se voit qui va
au cours de l'année il a dans ce
contexte c'est parce qu'on est très
impliqué dans la recherche on a fait un
appel mais qui est un appel limité à on
a demandé un million d'euros c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment bien
cadré par rapport à des recherches qu'on
souhaiterait mener aussi bien là si tu
passes tes heure de paris que
quelquefois en collaboration avec le
réseau international des instituts
pasteur mais donc on est sur une
procédure qui pour nous est assez
habituel par rapport à notre mode de
fonctionnement et notre mode de 2
d'acquisition des revenus alors le
dernier point sur les vaccins je crois
vous l'avez entendu les vaccins se sont
c'est quelque chose qui prend du temps
il y a beaucoup de l'équipe aujourd'hui
dans le monde qui sont engagés dans des
recherches vaccinale le calendrier
typiquement proposé c'est trois mois
mais ton pour le concept vaccin quelle
que soit la technologie utilisée
vous passez après chez l'animal vous
rajouter trois mois vous passez chez
l'homme pour voir si votre vaccin est
bien toléré pour voir si votre vaccin et
immunogène c'est à dire qu'il induit une
réponse immunitaire et enfin vous passer
l'épreuve du feu pouvoir c'est votre
vaccin protège et donc le calendrier
pour nous c'est typiquement 18 mois pour
les premiers essais je sais qu'il ya des
équipes qui dans le contexte de
l'urgence vont probablement aller plus
vite que ce soit en chine ou ailleurs
dans le monde
après je vous demande d'être là dessus
assez prudents parce que notre
expérience avec les vaccins
c'est que il ya beaucoup de maladies
pour lesquelles malheureusement on n'a
pas réussi à mettre avoir un vaccin
efficace et je rappelle que pour le
maire c'est le syndrome quand un virus
qui donc circuit dans les pays du golfe
ça fait six ans qui cherche un vaccin
qui n'ont pas encore réussi à mettre au
point donc c'est très important d'y
aller parce que si dans 18 mois
on est toujours dans une situation en
démo épidémique et si à ce moment là le
vaccin sera très important dans
l'arsenal de la réponse qu'on peut
apporter pour contrôler l'épidémie
mais il faut pas non plus faire peser
tous nos espoirs sur le vaccin parce que
à ce sera londres 2 ça ne marche pas
toujours
merci beaucoup nous allons continuer
avec madame la charade
merci monsieur le président merci à tous
ces éminents spécialistes de nous avoir
éclairé sur la question
bon je vais aller droit au but je suis
pédiatre et
je me demande s'il faut pas fermer les
salles d'attenté cabinet de consultation
de pédiatrie de pmi et voir les
prolonger les vacances scolaires sur
l'enfant étant asymptomatiques d'après
ce que j'ai compris ou très peu très peu
malade il se constituera inévitablement
à réservoir considérable et c'est un peu
illusoire dit luz et d'isoler les
patients contacte alors que les enfants
sont des patients au contact automatique
je me pose la question en particulier du
personnel entourant les enfants
particulier femme enceinte est ce qu'il
ya un risque comme dans la grippe plus
élevé chez la femme enceinte est ce
qu'il ya eu dsk eu des cas de décès chez
les femmes enceintes et par ailleurs
comme maintien libé ancien médecin
libéral
je me souviens des épidémies précédentes
la première fois on a reçu un kit avec
un masque ou deux la deuxième fois dans
les années 2000 six ou sept on s'est
équipé nous mêmes avec des stocks de
masques dont on s'est ensuite débarrassé
puisqu'ils étaient périmés comment le
gouvernement envisage-t-il des délais
les professions libérales en dehors de
l'information qui je crois circule bien
par ailleurs est ce que est ce que le
climat aura un effet est-ce que le un
hiver un peu prolongé aurait un effet
particulier et enfin si la chloroquine
était efficace
est-ce que n'autoriserait justement les
médecins a largement le prescrire y
compris sans avoir fait de tests
diagnostiques
moi je crois que c'est tout merci mais
mme berthé oui monsieur le président je
vaux merci merci beaucoup pour les
explications vous avez donné donc martin
verte est sénatrice de la savoie je
précise car c'est en lien avec ma
question je vous avais parlé donc de la
stratégie mise en place qui est celle de
freiner la diffusion bien sûr alors je
voudrais revenir sur le problème des
voyageurs et plus particulièrement sur
les trains transfrontaliers je pense au
train milan paris qui fait plusieurs
fois l'aller-retour entre l'italie qui
part de cette zone infectée par le
coronavirus pour se rendre à paris des
savoyards prennent ce train à modane et
à chambéry jeu j'aimerais savoir au delà
des messages de diffusion enfin diffusé
dans vous nous avez parlé
quelles procédures ont été mises en
place quelles consignes sont données
notamment voilà au personnel de la
police aux frontières qui fait des
contrôles journaliers aussi bien au
niveau du tunnel du fréjus que dans ce
train à la fois pour se protéger
eux-mêmes mais aussi pour détecter
d'éventuels malade et puis également
quelles consignes ont été données au
niveau de la sncf donc nous avons appris
que les contrôleurs doivent descendre à
modane mais pour les voyageurs qu'en est
il
j'ai une deuxième question qui concerne
la transparence donc vous nous avez
parlé de transparence nous avons appris
qu'il y à un cas détectés hospitalisés
en auvergne rhône-alpes elle nous a dit
qu'il s'agissait de l'est de la région
sans plus de précisions donc pourquoi
cette non transparence dans ce cas là et
puis également vous nous avez parlé
d'une distance de contact de 1 mètre et
donc un simple masque suffit qu'elle sur
quoi est basée cette cet élément laisse
absolument établis ou une approximation
bien sûr je le pense mais comment est-ce
que l'on peut rester sur cette donnée
n'est alors de la savoie on passe aux
caraïbes même jasmin et bien justement
j'avais parlé de la qualifie ce qu'il y
à beaucoup des changes qui se font et
merci beaucoup pour vos interventions
efficaces
il ya beaucoup les changes qui se font
entre nos différentes îles et il est
prévu une croisière bientôt allons moule
des personnes sont d'italie pour arriver
à la martinique et pour ensuite prendre
un bateau et là c'est sur les réseaux
sociaux les martiniquais sont très
inquiets parce qu'il ya des martiniquais
qui vont aussi prendre le même bateau
donc quelles sont les mesures qui sont
prises à ce niveau là mais d'autre part
il y a également entre la chine et la
dominique parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'investisseurs chinois qui sont à l'île
de la dominique et de gestion qui se
font ensuite par bateau entre lille et à
dominique est à la fois la martinique la
guadeloupe et d'autre part il ya des
vols internationaux qui arrive à saint
martin c'est martin et qui alors à
partir de ses marques et a beaucoup de
personnes qui viennent également dans
les autres îles alors quelles sont les
mesures qui sont prises et en termes de
prévention de communication c'est vrai
demain il y aura une réunion à
l'initiative de la rs de guadeloupe qui
s'occupe de la guadeloupe saint-martin
démantèlement mais en terme de
communication pour les différentes
langues pensent qu'à se monte à beaucoup
de communautés différentes et avec les
autres illégalement alors quelles sont
les mesures qui sont prises à la fois
pour les noms des trois français mais
aussi avec les autres îles dakar
hibino sont pas tous francophones
djaouabra merci merci je vous laisse
répondre merci beaucoup moi je vais
commencer par part vous répondre la
manade sénatrice parce que je suis très
attentif à ce que l'ensemble de la
communauté française répond de la même
façon en particulier nos départements
ultramarins et donc on est évidemment la
même démarche
la même réponse que ce soit pour la
réunion la guyane mayotte martinique et
guadeloupe qui n'ont évidemment pas du
tout la même organisation
mais l'idée qui est qu évidemment le
virus arrivera n'importe où mais ça je
pense que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
important de le faire penser il ya
aucune raison que les virus sorte dans
un endroit où tout est prêt et où il ya
parfaitement organisé l'accueil des
patients et donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui qui m'obsède depuis
plusieurs semaines tous les territoires
doivent être équipés à voir le test
savoir quoi faire et donc en particulier
pour les antilles les ars sont très
actives avec les préfets vous avez un
nouveau préfet en martinique et un
préfet de zone qui ont qui va qui va
gérer cette situation les ars
j'aurais demandé de faire beaucoup de
communication ce que je pense qu aux
antilles c'est très important de faire
la communication de proximité c'est
valable ailleurs mais encore plus
peut-être aux antilles on est très
attentif à la communication locale
directe en dents dans les mairies en
particulier donc on y travaille après
vous avez raison il ya des enjeux de
relations intra caraïbes voire même de
réponse pas au de l'om est sur cette
zone puisque on voit qu'aujourd'hui on a
peu d'informations épidémiologiques sur
sur cette zone mais il va falloir être
très attentif à l'ensemble de la zone et
en particulier moi je suis en relation
étroite avec le directeur général de la
grèce sur les sujets des croisières pas
parce que les croisières en soi sont à
risque mais parce qu'effectivement comme
il ya trois mille personnes sur un
bateau si vous mettez vous introduisez
des manades dans ce bateau c'est pas une
bonne idée
compte tenu de ce qu'ils de ce qu'on a
observé sur dimon princess je laisserais
parler des experts sur les distances
gouttelettes mais sur ce qui a été dit
par madame la sénatrice pour les femmes
enceintes et les enfants femmes
enceintes j'ai pas connaissance de
gravité particulière mais c'est vrai
qu'en évidemment on y est attentif sur
les enfants on n'a pas dit qu'ils
n'étaient pas symptomatique on aime on a
dit qu'il y avait pas de forme grave
donc ils peuvent être entre guillemets
vecteur avec des formes bénignes et donc
on a un vrai enjeu je crois au niveau
national et catherine de porc ne me
démentira pas je l'espère de créer un
réflexe de circuits infectieux en
pédiatrie en particulier qu'est ce que
je fais ce que je veux dire par circuit
affectueux en fait la bonne pratique
voudrait que quand on a une éruption
fébrile rougeole quand on a une diarrhée
fébrile très contagieuses ou quand on a
une tous fébriles on soit pris en charge
d'une façon spécifique et qu'on ne reste
pas quatre heures aux urgences au milieu
d'autres passions je pense que voilà non
mais déjà déjà en termes hospital et les
cabinets c'est évidemment évidemment un
sujet et donc vous avez posé des
questions très précises sur les écoles
et sur les vacances sur les écoles en la
faire puisque je vous rappelle qu'on
contamines montjoie
on a fermé trois écoles puisque le seul
cas pédiatriques qui d'ailleurs était en
parfaite état clinique
quand on a été le voir il n'était pas du
tout inquiète en avait pas été passée
par trois écoles
on a pris des mesures de fermeture des
écoles et on peut éventuellement les ans
l'envisager si on avait un foyer
quelques pas après la vraie difficulté
c'est que si on devait prendre ces
mesures et on les prendra peut-être
enfin son évolution de la situation
il ya une vraie difficulté doctrinal ou
de trine est requis et quand est ce
qu'on y trouvera parce que tant que le
virus circule n'y a pas tellement de
raison de dire que on laisse les écoles
ou alors c'est une mesure de confinement
d'endiguement de freinage de l'épidémie
sonic c'est un vrai enjeu de la même
façon on s'est rendu compte que les
enfants par exemple qui reviennent 2
non où circule activement les russes on
avait plutôt intérêt à la laisser aller
des céans 14/n à la maison parce qu'on
peut pas demander à un enfant en
particulier en âge scolaire de d'avoir
une réduction de vie sociale on peut
demander à un adulte d'éviter toutes les
réunions et d'aller voir quelqu'un de
fragile un enfant il a une spontanéité
sociale et donc on peut pas le lui dire
de garder un masque ou de se laver les
mains tous les quarts d'heure c'était
compliqué donc voilà on est on est sur
cette démarche sur les enfants on
travaille évidemment beaucoup avec les
pédiatres notamment libéraux sur les
masques alors c'est très important et on
est en train de prendre des décisions
actuellement donc le ministre
s'exprimera ce soir sur cette doctrine
des masques sur le lac c'est au mas il
ya évidemment une doctrine importante
qui est celle que je vous ai rappelé sur
les masques chien d'un côté et les
masques protecteurs de l'autre les
masques périmés en soi ne sont pas
spécifiquement périmés sont périmés pour
les élastiques
donc c'est pas si grave que ça en
pratique que c'est pas le masque
lui-même mais c'est une inquiétude du
fabricant soit l'élastique donc c'est
plutôt rassurant mais par contre on a on
a un stock stratégique de masques
chirurgicaux et une commande de masques
spécifiques pour les professionnels de
santé
donc la question pour moi la plus
importante et on est en train de
discuter avec les collègues
professionnels libéraux c'est comment
est ce qu'on trouve un système
extrêmement simple vraiment très très
simple et très accessible d'accès aux
masques on va éviter le l'usiné à gaz je
pense que l'idée c'est d'aller de
trouver au plus près de son cabinet
surtout quand on est en libéral
probablement avec l'appui des officines
ben voilà il faut que ce soit très
simple très facile vraiment en deux
minutes qu'on puisse récupérer des
masques et c'est ça que ce type de
dispositif qu'on va présenter
probablement dès ce soir
[Musique]
donc juste une chose attendons de voir
déjà c'est là que le rookie d'un effet
je pense que pour l'instant c'est
prématuré de de voir comment elle
pourrait être utilisée c'est une piste
intéressante parce que c'est évidemment
un médicament qui est disponible qui a
peu d'effets indésirables quitte là
mêmes et cetera donc on a mais après
regardons déjà les données plus
précisément je pense que ont presté tué
ensuite
juste un mot on a parlé du climat dans
le climat c'est vrai qu'il ya des on
sait qu'un certain nombre de virus
respiratoires sont saisonniers qui
préfèrent les prepared hivernale se
tient à deux choses peut-être en partie
le fait que certains virus résiste mieux
dans le froid et le climat sec mais
c'est aussi parce que pendant des
périodes hivernales des gens vivent
beaucoup plus en intérieur confiné et
que les mâles y transpire respiratoires
se transmettent plus facilement donc il
faut voir que voilà alors le deuxième
élément que jérôme salomon souffle et
celui effectivement du chronobus du
maire ce donc j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui est encore d'un virus qui vit dans
les pays du golfe et donc résiste bien
aux températures élevées donc je crois
que pour l'instant on peut pas statuer
sur la pac corps et éventuellement un
réchauffement des températures avec
l'arrivée du printemps et de l'été même
si je sais que le président américain
était sur ce point c'est optimiste alors
ensuite je je passe maintenant sur une
question qui reste est que j'avais noté
la distance à laquelle on doit être par
rapport aux risques de transmission
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya pas deux il
faut pas le voir comme quelque chose de
blanc noir on est obligé d'avoir une
règle pour se faciliter la tâche parce
que quand vous faites par exemple c'est
le travail de santé publique france et
des ars l'investigation des personnes
qui ont été en contact avec un malade
vous avez des dizaines de personnes qui
sont concernées et qui vont être amenés
à des niveaux de 2,2 d'isolement
confinement qui seront qui dépendront de
si on pense qu'ils ont un contact étroit
ou un contact qu'on considère à risque
plus faible
la distance qu'on utilise doit mettre à
mettre 50 cc des postillons parce qu'on
sait que dans la transmission les
postillons sur le principal vecteur
alors vous me direz j'arrivais à envoyer
des postures à 2 mais j'arrive à envoyer
à 50 cm je suis d'accord avec vous il ya
un moment où il faut il ya un moment où
il faut mettre une règle
pour faciliter la tâche des personnes
qui vont faire le travail il ya des
travaux plus sérieux qui ont été faire
le il ya des publications pas rendues et
mighty qui ont regardé des gens tousser
éternuer et qui mesure la distance à
laquelle sa part donc et est donc voilà
c'est pour vous dire que c'est pas non
plus complètement laissée à
l'appréciation personnelle
le message ici c'est que effectivement
on sait aussi par la nature même des
personnes qui sont affectées qu'il
s'agit soit des personnels soignants qui
sont très exposés notamment quand ils
font des manoeuvres ce que disait jérôme
salomon tout à leur type invitation et
c'est parce qu'ils sont proches d'un
patient qui est ce moment là bas il
mettre ces gouttelettes
il ya aussi les contacts familiaux parce
que là aussi on a des contacts plus
étroits donc l'expérience nous montre
aussi que cette règle finalement d'un
contact étroit a une signification
épidémiologique pratique qui qui qui
marche assez bien après il y aura des
exceptions on en est tous conscient et
je rappellerai aussi le rôle de la
transmission qu'on appelle manu portée à
qui a déjà été évoqué c'est à dire que
vos postillons et vous restez sur des
surfaces inerte que dans un milieu quand
même un peu humide et bien le virus peut
rester alors là vous verrez toutes les
études ou vous dira trois heures 6
heures un peu plus je pense qu'on va pas
essayé d'argumenter là dessus a peu
d'intérêt ce qui est important en
revanche c'est de se souvenir que cette
transmission manuportée ça veut dire que
l'hygiène des mains doit être
extrêmement strictes et ça c'est quelque
chose que vous faites quelle que soit la
distance de vaud postillons et que les
donc c'est une hygiène des mains est
aussi savoir et apprendre à ne pas
porter ses mains sa bouche a sonné parce
que c'est comme ça que vous allez
affecter vos muqueuses
ma chaîne même le port de trois
précisions pour compléter ce qui a été
dit à propos de la transmission mère
enfant en fait on dispose de très peu de
données à ce jour donc disponible mais
en tous les cas sur les petites séries
qui aurait pu être publiés on n'a pas la
pression qui est une transmission mère
enfant qui puisse exister ou en tous les
cas si elle existe et elle serait sans
doute extrêmement faible je ne dis pas
qu'elles n'existent pas mais en tous les
cas les données ne vont pas en faveur
d'une transmission mère enfant comme on
a pu la connaître par exemple pour le
vih qui initialement sans traitement
était de 30% par exemple donc on n'est
pas on n'a vraiment pas du tout
l'impression d'être dans ce schéma là
mais évidemment il faut disposer de plus
de données pour pouvoir être être
extrêmement vigilant bien entendu sur ce
plan-là sûr je veux juste compléter ce
qu'a dit arnaud fin d'année sur
l'évaluation du niveau de risque et en
fonction de la proximité mais aussi du
temps passé il faut être à la fois dans
une distance courte mais aussi pendant
dix ans attend de l'ordre de 30 à
minutes à 60 minutes
donc effectivement ce sont des éléments
qui sont utilisés poire santé public
français avec les ars
quand on fait l'investigation des
contacts en particulier pour des secours
les classer selon un niveau de risque
élevé modéré et sert à chaque fois qu'on
a un doute on va classer les contacts
dans un niveau de risque supérieure si
vous voulez pour être dans une situation
toujours cohérentes avec l'idée de
casser les chaînes de transmission
autant que nécessaire donc chaque fois
qu'on a un doute
évidemment on prend toutes les
précautions nécessaires et d'ailleurs
sur les plusieurs centaines de contacts
niveau de risque élevé qu'on a pu
comptabiliser jusqu'à présent et suivre
on n'a pas vu de cas paraître donc voilà
c'est effectivement un point important
est le rappel des gestes barrières et de
l'hygiène je ne saurais trop également à
nouveau le rappeler dans une situation
dispose pas ni traitement ni de vaccin
et donc on doit absolument rappeler ces
mesures là oui je reviens sur les
antilles un instant puisque directeur
général a fait part de sa préoccupation
hier c'était très concrètement que ce
fameux syndrome de détresse respiratoire
aiguë et est discuté avec les collègues
des antilles guadeloupe et martinique
et concrètement la mission coreb avec la
société de réanimation est en train de
mettre en place aujourd'hui une échange
de pratiques pour que les comportements
qui vont être extrait de cette
expérience puisse servir à tous
donc ils sont complètement intégrés dans
le c'est cette approche de multi
professionnels et multisites et
simplement ils nous ont soumis à cette
attention que si les tests marchait
vraiment bien ce serait bien et ça a
l'air très très proches mais c'est quand
même une révolution tout re encore plus
que bien sûr ça ne l'a été pour le
territoire ils sont conditions plus
difficiles pour cet aspect ce c'était
une remarque je ferai une remarque sur
le le climat le climat est pas le seul
déterminant est juste rappeler ici que
le sénat a accueilli il ya quelques
années toute une discussion autour du
rapport sur les maladies infectieuses
émergentes que nous avions a animé dans
le cadre d'un rapport au conseil de
santé publique qu'il ya un certain
nombre de déterminants de l'émergence
des maladies infectieuses au sens large
qui dépasse très largement les activités
humaines que les deux principaux
facteurs ce sont les voyages
[Rires]
les voyages et la consommation en
particulier pour les antibiotiques bien
entendu voilà le sénat soutien s'est
régulièrement la poursuite de cette
activité de séminaires maladies
infectieuses émergentes qui resitue
l'émergence des maladies humaines dans
leur interaction avec le monde animal le
monde végétal et l'environnement et que
tu une vision beaucoup plus large qui
est intéressante toujours quand on est
face à des incertitudes et à apprendre
aussi beaucoup de deux de ses collègues
voilà et puis je dirais que le 1 m que
vous venez de disputer sous tous les
angles est imaginable mois mains vides
qu'on pose la question comme tout le
monde bien entendu m'invite à rappeler
que man mes premiers professeurs de
réanimation médicale à l'hôpital claude
bernard ou maladies infectieuses il y a
un certain temps interdisait aux
personnes dans son service de se serrer
la main et a fortiori de s'embrasser il
nous avait appris à nous saluer à la
mode chinoise et je vous encourage à
tester oui bah oui mais ya à prendre et
à apprendre de tous c'est très important
parce que c'est très important
c'est très important parce que ça crée
dans l'état d'esprit des gens cette
notion de distance
la distanciation c'est c'est la première
mesure et sait comment rester convivial
et dans l'accueil on n'a pas parlé
d'accueil peut-être assez mais l'accueil
des personnes malades et quelque chose
de clés si on veut qu'il fasse confiance
au système de santé
donc là que ça prend du temps ça
comporte des gestes et le fait de à la
fois accueillir quelqu'un mais en lui
exprimant le besoin de maintenir une
certaine distance et je vous essentiel
merci avant de passer la parole au
collègue
je voudrais m'adresser
gouvernement directement parce que
d'abord vous n'avez pas répondu aux
angoisses des savoyards qu'il faudra
répondre ensuite hier matin à gare tgv
d'avignon j'ai rencontré des concitoyens
qui affolée et said acheter des masques
et n'en trouveront plus en pharmacie il
s'adresse à amazon ou pour l'instant les
masques amazon sont vendu 3 euros pièce
sauf que les stocks sont épuisés et il
ya d'autres sites actuellement qui sont
en place et les concitoyens que j'ai vus
ont acheté parce que affolés trois
masques pour 140 euros sur des sites
actuellement il ya des sites qui
profitent de la situation pour et c'est
donc j'alerte le gouvernement sur le
sujet si vous le voulez bien
si vous le voulez bien est ce président
je répandrai directement donc à la fois
à la question de la sénatrice de sa voix
sur les transports
c'est important je vais dire que ce
sujet entre guillemets va disparaître
assez vite
compte tenu du fait que le virus est en
train de se répandre en suisse en
allemagne en espagne et donc de toutes
façons soit on considère que ont alarmé
des mesures barrières mais que c'est des
mesures barrières individuel soit la
question va se poser parce que en
pratique dans les trains il ya les
avions il ya les tunnels et l maritime
et à une relation très fort par exemple
entre l'italie et la corse
de toute façon les flux sont sont
importants par contre que vous avez dit
sur les contrôleurs en fait c'est une
décision de leur part de descendre et de
se faire remplacer par leurs collègues
italiens et sur les masques c'est très
important pour nos concitoyens le
ministre l'a dit mais je le redis il ya
des stocks stratégiques importants
détenus par santé publique françois les
masques chirurgicaux
donc on n'a pas d'inquiétude la seule
chose c'est une c con on attend parce
qu'il ya une logique on ne distribue des
masques que quand c'est nécessaire et
donc évidemment aux malades au contact
dans la zone où circule le virus donc si
demain on nous dit qu'il ya une zone où
un département où le virus circule
évidemment compris villers et on
privilégiera cette zone pour que les
personnes qui sont concernées puissent
avoir des masques donc on est plutôt sur
une réserve stocks mais il n'y a pas de
sujet de pénurie et j'encourage nos
concitoyens pas se faire avoir par des
escroqueries
parce qu'entre nous ne sais pas du tout
le prix d'un masque en particulier
chirurgicale donc voilà rassurés de
rassurer on le dira beaucoup enfin
presque faut pas s'inquiéter l'autre
merci bien et voilà pour cette audition
sur le coronavirus sur les risques qu'il
représente est sur les mesures prises
par les pouvoirs publics
la commission des affaires sociales
entendez donc ce matin plusieurs experts
sur ce sujet qui occupe largement
l'actualité je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez retrouver tous les articles
et toutes les émissions de la rédaction
sur notre site internet publicsenat.fr
c'est la fin de cette émission je vous
souhaite une excellente journée
[Musique]